esta pistola dispara olhe dois ipads
pessoal de quem fala da que sejam muito
bem vindos a mais um pneu e os trabalhos
de que mais um brinquedo olha só pra só
vou também disse que ele é muito grande
e uma pistola dispara coisas vão bem
porque bosco está ou não eu acho que
isso orbes jobs é que elas vão lhes pedi
nada pessoal esta pistola dispara órbita
como podem ver eu tarde fará agora estou
presente porque vamos lá unha que
prestem muita gente eu sou nem seu maior
freguês mulheres não estão ex tudo assim
não deu chances a 85 fita é um deus para
85 pés que é o equivalente a
aproximadamente 50 metros
acho que é isso em 2000 ou 2001 também
não compreende o que a gente puder não
foi só de trás
aí muito louco e equilíbrio bombinhas
play tem muitas jovens e que nem eu
espero e kristen é orbis lá dentro
porque eu não tenho ordens aqui em casa
eu espero que venha com a munição não é
porque não via com munição não vou
descartar nada mas pra lá de casa
pessoal mas antes eu conto muito com o
vosso life escrito pensei muito muito
muito mesmo muito aqui no estúdio laika
equivalentes a continuada de ordem se
tem aqui dentro se não tiver nenhuma
pronta eu não vou ter aqui no estúdio
lecce pela caixa e três filhos
se vocês forem escrever aqui no canal
desde os grãos
a visita de cristo não é isso vocês não
foi inscrito no canal pessoal inscrevam
e partilhem com os vossos amigos
inimigos família e kehl barata música eu
acho que a música te vai gostar de ver
isso e agora também se bem que nós não
podemos retirar elaborado e construído o
anel flui para abrir esta caixinha para
cuja primeira pessoa é muito bonita lei
o que não sei mas eu gosto do que mais
manda lesão e vem senhor biggs ou meus
filhos não têm uma escala tão só tem
caixinha por enquanto só tem ordens de
jorge jesus falou vou contar uma 2016
para fora mas sei que tem 500 cortes ou
seja 500 1000 1500 2000 urbs 30 a ordem
é ser que a china e agora estava em toda
desmontada como sempre vou ter que
montar isso mas temos instruções na mala
com câmeras por onde eu não me ensinaram
na escola ensinar o homem livre
tem muita instrução aqui mas não receber
a palavra nossa história do partido
não posso abrir isso aí sim eu tenho que
ir com calma mandato desde que transmito
área é manusear as coisas comenta calma
só estão espírito 23 pontos
[Música]
portanto aquela parte de gás assim né
isso é muito forte
vamos abrir um cachorrinho olha só eu é
muito grande o lê isso
olha aí fica aí fica aí o pessoal aí tem
aqui uma coisa eo a gente toma assim ai
para uma ocorrência
ai funghi supostamente estava sinai
porque agora vamos colocar as balas e
que encima supostamente na orangina
eu acho que tem que ter mais calma mesmo
maluco aqui como é que isso funciona
eu acho que não é uma coisa que se chama
manual sabe por onde é que só encaixou
como fazer só tem essa aqui na imagem
não pode acreditar apenas gente pensa
não enrola ataque outra falha foi do
jogo foi o jovem com água dentro do
baixão é muito sinuoso história aquela
mesmo assim é e continua não sei porque
eu acho que abriu alguns ali dentro
então é só encaixar aqui né
só estas ruas nossas forbes
olha só como é que fica porque é muito
ruim a já percebi isso aqui é um
pouquinho para nós fazer uns pés fora
escuro e aqui dentro ou seja isto a
psique que tem que abrir o e sim agora é
só colocar os nossos jovens não deixei
muitas
[Música]
daí acho que seria suficiente ela já foi
completamente submersas ok agora eu vou
fechar creche e já está aí agora é só
esperar e eu estou muito muito rápido o
lixo fica grande
ele só olha aí também japão aumentaram
na área caiu agora vou deixar aqui de
parte porque porque nós já temos algumas
fórmulas prontas então são esses que nós
vamos usar o primeiro envolve um
tribunal é muito bom
eu sei eu sei que a briga mas fracassou
a bancada se limita só pegamos acabar
goleiros instruções já coloquei jovens
cá em cima
já coloquei mais forbes a fazer dentro
da nossa outra caixinha mas que falta
mais agora é só puxar para trás e que
sim
este texto é coisa que goldi ele liso ou
seja tem que andar pra trás e rolou para
trás
o senhor pode falar disparou
03 21 vai voltar num copo para 32
foi muito rápido mas tive que vai ter 50
metros então eu vou testar isso só vou
tentar fazer uma torre
só uma coisa que eu não gosto dessa
história é que supostamente deveria dar
para disparar e que mas não eu tenho que
achar que tinha tudo pra trás pois
largar e só aí é a hora de sair e isso é
um pouco chato porque não dá pra virar
muito bem mas funciona funciona mas bola
fazer o desvio por cima da hora e aí
pessoal daqui uma hora e 32 de
participação na empresa agora possui 31
vai ainda tem muitas muitas jovens em
mexe eu ainda não descobri o copo esse é
o principal agora 32 moradora vamos
fazer ainda mais difícil no entanto vai
atirar um copo para cima e eu vou tentar
dar o bote
só consigo mais difícil que não serve
não só comentei em baixa o que vocês
acham que vai acontecer é dark vai
falhar o país está de fora é tentar
acertar a mão meu deus
o objetivo é tentar acertar aqui num
sinal do denver
não é fácil mas 3 2 1
você pega por aqui
olha aqui a matéria mas foi uma maneira
de atrair muitos lute no uso que vou
tentar fazer agora é dar um estilo na
piscina e ver como é que a ordem ea
china o china porque lei água nem eu não
sei se elas vão ficar maior por ficar e
lá eu não sei como está pra lá quando
ela só em três torres vontade de chorar
eu acho que nossa filha
agora foi o que foi
sim sou normal
primeiro porque é uma área muito pequena
e também é zuera tinha também é isso
então é muito difícil ver qualquer coisa
[Música]
aqui tem muita gente olha tenho lá no
fundo mia tem outra lenta e outra ali eu
pegasse estava dentro da piscina com
borda mas eu acho que precisava de 10
milhões
pessoalmente isso querem que a china com
muitas ordens porque as nossas portas
estão quase a acabar vamos ver como é
que estão aquelas que eu preparei para
lá agora então isso alves nossas forbes
estão prontas
eu suspeito que já estão mais para lá
ver em 321 envolvido juntamente com
vocês e estão quase prontas olha só como
é que fica o homem que a lei é muito
linda
imagina fazer uma hora dizia que só
comenta e também se quiserem web gigante
e assim não não é tão grande assim diego
continua enorme é uma grande equipe como
é uma rotina portuguesa ainda dentro da
hora de morrer muito grande mas é
possível que só vocês querem ver isso eu
não sei que emitem manual de instruções
descritas pobres moram quatro horas e
ficar grande e eu não vou esperar esse
tempo não tem quatro horas é muito tempo
só esperar por horas mas isso não é
problema porque nós acabamos por do
estado a nossa pistola por completo na
época já tinha aqui muito jovens ainda
bem que os enviaram estas obras prontas
mas não tinha que ficar quatro horas
perante de experimentar o brinquedo mas
a gente só vai ficar aqui com espírito
espero que vocês tenham gostado já sabem
que se quiserem ver mais vídeos de cinco
brinquedos cometer em baixo e o próximo
vídeo vai ser uma experiência portanto
fiquei prevê já sabe quanto o nosso
primeiro é que nos filho filho foram
inscritos inscreva se e e só fiquem bem
até a próxima
[Música]